you
I'm gonna start with this give my queen
some air give my bishop some air and wow
okay well considered g3 silently and
well first off let's try this one Bishop
f2 throwing a punch at a seven
threatening to win the rook in two moves
so I was going to say I need to clear
out four pieces before I Castle kingside
yeah and what I really want to Castle
Queen side hmm this guy is bound to give
me some problems okay that has been
stopped this threat I thought better was
night here now how does he develop and
this weakens this light square diagonal
hmm decision time yeah I thought night
just might develop was better there I'm
thinking about night be three or g4 not
sure um let's go with night out get some
more development and maybe I get my
other night right here Castle Queen side
yeah and then you know what I might want
to get a little bit more out of my Jeep
on g3 says I'm helping my Bishop g4 says
I'm helping my rook my bishop and even
my bishop my bishop in the corner and my
[ __ ] up on f2 since this move is maybe
still available so certainly more
aggressive oh okay well do I want to
keep my pawn or I do I want to defend my
pawn or take me
just wanna go on step sorry about that
little coffin there Knight c3 queenside
castle is looking more and more
appealing now that stuff is going to
open up on the side of the board I think
this is going to be a safer home for my
king and when I do that he'll stay on c1
and he'll just be playing here okay
let's get another night out i'm fine
with any Bishop takes on my nights just
you know just be fine with that I think
I want to consider if Bishop takes
Knight here I'll want to consider taking
away from the center as taking like this
is a bit too weakening maybe I don't
even need to declare my Kings intentions
just yet though again I'm certainly
leaning towards the Queen side hmm oh
hang on yeah you know what my opponent
has made one developing move I have a
lead in development and with this next
one I can well I'm developing I'm trip
nah I don't know if I could call
developing but I'm throwing a pond in
the center with tempo Queen takes a six
thank you to Magnus McDuck I saw that
pop up there thank you for the
subscription queenside castle pond push
is also a threat yeah pop push is also a
threat because this Bishop will the door
will be slammed on the bishop if this is
allowed so I don't have to take right
away i'm winning material here no I
don't know that there was a great way to
even defend that all right if this move
I could have considered Bishop to a
seven so I think I take first this is
going to be really bad news soon for
black yeah really bad news night-night
block is a must otherwise of the night
drops a night block I take
the bishop and then I'm back on with the
serious threat oh that's big trouble now
that's a free night check the rook has
to go back and I'm going to go back here
I'm going to take here no matter what
okay Knights pinned and I'm up a piece I
just want to get my king castled and it
should be smooth road to victory okay
that's weakening this guy here not even
going to take them though I just want to
get developed complete development and
get this rook doing something route to e
one guess I'll give a check now let's
grab this pond and then maybe come back
here with check in Dulce six and then
finally drop back somewhere else all
right e six I guess it's helpful to the
Queen all right yeah Bishop back here or
keep the pawn in a pin my bishops
vulnerable on this square which it takes
here is happening soon I'm on that pond
twice now just take it all right let's
take him out now I have moves like this
pawn takes I'll just recapture my rook
will get very active and he's vulnerable
as well night here is also worth
considering night to d4 it's just
pinned peace not be six he's it's all
locked up there was I think everything
is really pointing back to this night be
sick this be six move instead of night
to be six yeah okay let's get here my
work isn't doing anything this is maybe
a threat to place f5 and I don't know
that I need to do anything with my night
rook takes rook takes rook here is a
serious threat and oh there's even this
okay this is big trouble to clean house
to block I even have these ideas of
Knight takes rook takes Queen a8 rook
block and Queen takes c6 something I
didn't consider it either yeah the queen
is going to be gone at that point all
right good game let's go back I think
this is just a very early decision with
v6 that really made made it problematic
to get the rest of your pieces out
really a unique set up here usually well
not usually but there are many positions
where just after a handful of moves
it'll start to look something like some
something we're familiar with like a
Sicilian or an English dragon but what
these nights place how they are it's
it's hard to imagine that happening but
anyhow okay with this configuration I
don't really see that showing up yeah
this right here I think you have to
throw your night out this is way to
weakening without any fear of doubled
pawns that's that suit that would be
super helpful so if that was one of the
reasons why you wouldn't want to
night to be six know that it's fine
Knight b6 Bishop takes you take towards
the center and your rook is going to
have some nice play over here so Knight
b6 is going to be better and now this is
just wide open is it's weakens weakens
your light squares right and this is
where it really went downhill as soon as
soon as i got my pawn rolling is you
know I I could have even considered this
right now to push my pond just to get my
queen here it's just way too weakening
and it can it can be very difficult into
the game it was certainly difficult
these light squares got pounced on hi I
think I think of the computer if we
throw this commission on some computer
it would already be reading that white
is flat-out winning just too much
development too many weaknesses over
here it can happen that quickly in
Fisher in this this setup here because
now where's your night gonna go it's not
just about weakening the light squares
it's like well where where's he going to
go now you need to move this guy that's
more weakening moves right next to your
king you need four pieces to move before
you even think about going on the King
side which after g5 this is now not so
great home for your king you really had
to play as far back as moved to this
Knight b6 move instead of b6 it was just
way too weakening is able to get into
the light squares grabbing upon getting
into the light squares night would have
to block here but it's still going to be
a tough road ahead if you went in that
direction okay good game let's close out
of this
you